i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight can the conservative party win
again under boris johnson's leadership
confirmation of the result the
conservatives have formally won this
general election uh i can report as
returning officer
uh that 359
ballots were cast if you ask yourselves
what is this new government going to do
what is he going to do with the
extraordinary majority i will tell you
that is what we are going to do we are
going to unite and level up that the
vote in favour
uh of having confidence in boris
johnson's theater was 211 votes and to
all those who voted for us for the first
time
and those whose pencils may have wavered
over the ballot thank you for the trust
you have placed in us
and in me and we will work round the
clock to repay
your trust and to deliver on your
priorities and the vote against was 148
votes
and therefore
i can announce that the parliamentary
party does have confidence
[Applause]
it's an extremely good
positive conclusive decisive result
which enables us to move on
to
unite and to focus on delivery and that
is exactly what we're gonna do
boris johnson wants to draw a line under
this week's rebellion
but the brightest lines being drawn
right now mark the chasm dividing the
conservative party
for many of the party's supporters the
johnson magic remains potent it broke
through the red wall and can do so again
they say
[Music]
to others the boris brand is toxic they
say it's poisoning conservative
prospects everywhere
our choice
must the tories drop the pilot or can
they find another path to victory
in the next 30 minutes three passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight former cabinet minister
david gork
craig whittaker the conservative mp for
call de valley and former minister anne
whitaker
today we're sort of proving that not all
uh
conflicts are binary the conflict
roiling the conservative party has
well at least three sides if not more
and they're represented here tonight let
me start with you and whitakam you
actually stood against the conservative
party uh in the european elections um
why do you care and why do you think
boris johnson has to stay in office
the reason that i care is because i
don't want to see the labor party in
office it really is as simple as that
and therefore what i want to see is a
strong conservative party even though i
left it and have not and i underlined
that have not rejoined and that is not
an accident that is a carefully
considered decision
but nevertheless um i want a
conservative agenda i want the leveling
up agenda i want loan taxes none of
which i really see at the moment but if
i'm to get that i don't need labor and
therefore to me the question now is the
conservative party decided yesterday
that it was that it had confidence in
boris now whether one wishes that they
come to a different view doesn't
actually matter that's where we are
and i'm well aware as a practicing
politician but it's no good hoping for
something different you have to look at
where you are and so
can they win with boris i think they can
but it depends on two things first of
all it depends on boris himself
getting his act together and getting
policies that will appeal to the public
and which they don't want to see
jeopardized
but it also depends on his party
and if those who resent yesterday's
result just carry on being fractures
being rebellious making things awkward
and what the public sees is a party
divided against itself what i've said
many times in in writing recently an
undisciplined rap
that's what they see they don't vote for
that okay thank you that's pretty clear
david gawk um hadn't you had you not had
you not lost your seat i guess uh you'd
have voted to throw mr johnson out um
do you think they should try again
i think ultimately they will have to do
that um i think there is a real
difficulty for the conservative party
going into the next general election led
by boris johnson
it does appear on all the polling
evidence that we have is that the public
have lost their trust
in boris johnson
i also think whether he's popular or not
there are certain standards that should
be expected of our politicians
particularly our prime minister and he
has fallen below those standards
um whether that is uh breaching the
rules to be honest i'm more worried
about the fact that
looks very much like he has mislead
parliament and i don't think that is
something that is acceptable and if we
are to have trust in our politics there
has to be consequences for behaving
badly like that
and for those reasons i think it would
be bad for the country
for the conservative party to be led by
boris johnson at the next general
election so it's not just a matter of
him but the what it says about politics
overall yes it is yes and i i think
integrity
should matter and i think he's fallen
below the standards that we should
expect to our politicians and as i say i
think he should pay a price for that uh
craig whitaker you um voted no
confidence uh last night you lost
and now you want us to move on
why
um well i'm surprised you say that
trevor because i had actually haven't
declared how i voted last night forgive
me um uh so it is not true uh that i uh
have declared that i voted against the
prime minister at all
um but what i did do of course was ask
the prime minister to resign in fact i
think i was the
definitely one of the first first or
second mp to ask him to resign when he
was
fined when he when he got his fixed term
uh fixed penalty notice
uh uh because in my view you can't make
the laws and then break the laws a
little bit like david was saying and i
took the very same stance
when dominic cummings did the same thing
and went to barnard castle
that to me wasn't any different and that
was my beef with him but it was very
clear then
that the prime minister wouldn't resign
and
i have always said
that to submit a letter to the 1922
committee was futile uh because he would
always win that vote
so actually uh forgive me you're quite
right to take me to the task for
presuming how you voted but let's just
uh deal with what you what you said um
basically you do want him out but you
would like the process to be
in a way a slightly old-fashioned
process by which the men in grey suit or
men and women grade suits now uh
essentially go and say to him
the gig's up no what i want the prime
minister to do is take responsibility
for his actions uh my constituents
expect me to do so and i expect him as
the leader of the country to do exactly
that and it comes down to
standards in public life
uh that's a position i take but you know
it's like with all battles we fight
whether it's political or in in life
itself
uh there comes a point when you you have
to accept that actually you're not going
to win that battle the mere fact that
it's taken nearly six months for 54
letters to go into the 1922 committee
would tell you that actually you're not
on the winning side of winning that
battle so in my view we draw a line
under it i've made my views publicly
very well known
and we get on and do what we're employed
to do and what we're elected to do and
that is get on and manage the country so
yeah so we can we can summarize here and
would come says never labor and if boris
johnson does that
makes that happen then whatever we'll
put up boris jonathan david gawk you're
sort of never boris really and um uh
craig you're essentially of the view
we had a shot and now it's all people
had their shot and now we need to get on
with the actual business of government
let's just start with this and would
come both uh craig whitaker and david
gawk are essentially saying this is a
matter of
if you like standards
probity
the image of politics overall that does
not away with you at all
well one thing i have always been
meticulous about
um both in my career as a politician and
as a journalist is to say
um that justice must be impartial and
you must wait for results before you
rush in and pass judgment
now if he is considered to have
deliberately
lied to the house and i stressed
underlined three times deliberately uh
then yes that is a completely different
matter um but it is perfectly possible
to make a statement that is misleading
um in good faith now what he said was
and i laughed at the time but i don't
laugh now because i better understand it
what he said was well he thought
the event that he was fined for he
thought it was a work break it was a
break between work sessions with
colleagues that he'd been with all day
and working with all day and he thought
it brought well no
let me finish this
he thought it was work right kyo stamina
interestingly has produced exactly the
same excuse that if he genuinely thought
it was a work right we should give him
the benefit of that that i don't know
i'm only interrupting you anne because
we've been over that ground but what's
very interesting to me about what you've
just said is that you can clearly
envisage a situation in which boris
johnson
should have to go or you would believe
uh
he would have to go if
the
inquiries or we we acquire some new
knowledge about uh what whether what he
said was actually true or not is that
correct that you can still envision a
situation in which boris johnson has to
step down
but what he said may have been factually
inaccurate that may have been said in
good faith and that that is the
distinction that i make and i don't know
other people are investigating this i'm
not maybe i'm the only one in the
country who doesn't actually decide that
i know what happened uh until i see a
full um report so on the lying that is
we've had the report on on the parties
so uh i um
you know i reserve judgment but what i
would say is this if we haven't got time
frankly or the conservative party hasn't
got time uh if we're going to wait
uh and then uh have um
another debate over the position of the
prime minister and he doesn't resign and
there's another confidence motion and
then there's a prolonged leadership
election you know we have in time there
isn't time to do all that and win the
next election okay can you imagine a
situation between now and next election
where we revisit this or can you imagine
a situation where we stopped talking
about it
well i mean the the there isn't any more
processes now that allows what happened
yesterday to happen again for the next
year and by that time were were
literally on top of the general election
before you leave that are you sure is it
poss not possible for the 1922 committee
to decide it wants to change the rules
and have another go at this in three
months time or six months time i am sure
the 1922 committee can try to do
whatever they wish but the reality is
they have to get that through the
parliamentary party and i doubt
very much that will happen do you both
agree with that david and anne no i'm
not sure that that is necessarily right
uh on the basis of what happened with
theresa may
where it didn't get to the stage of
changing the rules but but essentially
the committee of the 1920 that the
executive of the 1922 committee was
saying we will change the rules and we
will have another confidence those even
though it was only five months or so
previously that she had won one so so i
think it is possible the question is is
whether there is something significant
enough that that that forces them to do
that uh and that may happen it may not
happen but i think it is possible that
those rules will be changed all right
before i come back to you craig
i think
yes i think that what craig said what
craig said is absolutely right now the
1922 committee might well as david
postulates decide it wants to do that
but it's still the rule changes have
still got to be voted on by the party
and this is the party which has just
given boris johnson a vote of confidence
so frankly you know are they going to
get on with it and try and win the next
election or are they going to get bogged
down votes all right craig let's go back
to the issue of substance wrong process
i just want to get clear let's assume
that you're right and uh that that isn't
going to happen um can you see a
situation
in which this just drags on
as an albatross around the neck of the
party well it's quite interesting my
inbox my inbox is never a good judge of
any character i might put a caveat in
that but my my inbox yesterday i had 250
emails about the vote yesterday today
i've had two emails
you know it's just fallen off a cliff
people do move on the general public
definitely move on
and you know we're talking about 18
months two years before the next general
election
there is a great many things in that
time frame where the prime minister can
show
exactly why people gave him an 80
seat majority at the last election
because when the premise is on form he's
on real form
and what would he have to do to
demonstrate to you
uh that you could come on a program like
this and say
i'm 100
for boris johnson leading us into the
next election uh well i i'm already at
that stage i am one of these that as i
said earlier you know that the battle's
been fought we move on we have to go on
like but you did say before that you
thought he had to go
oh absolutely but that is out of my my
uh jurisdiction for him to take
responsibility i've made my position
very very clear with him
but it's clear that he's not going to go
it's not going to take responsibility in
my view
so we draw a line under it and we move
on the british people will decide at the
next general election
or whether they feel uh he is worthy not
to lead our country
so you know why should a small
constituency of
360 mps decide
on who our prime minister should be when
actually that job is the role of the
british people and i don't care hammer
away but it's it
i think some viewers would find it
rather strange that you were i think the
second mp to call france go
but youth now say that you can go and
knock on doors and say
yes we want this guy to lead our nation
for another five years
well uh you know i can take you up to
the calder valley and accept the call
the valley is very different to other
parts of the country and i can tell you
what what i'm currently finding or have
been finding knocking those doors i go
on what i would call a traditional
hardcore
tory middle income middle class family
knock on the door and they are angry
with him
absolutely angry with him but they won't
go and vote labor they may vote green or
lib dem as a protest vote as we saw in
the local elections but when a general
election comes comes through they will
probably vote for them if i go knock on
my aspirational working-class doors
they love him to bits and i can tell you
once you strip out the labor and the
momentum
campaigns we've had in our mailbox and
you have a look at the hardcore
emails
it is 50 50 and calling for him to
resign i can tell you i had as much
abuse from boris supporters as i did
from those that want to see him go
um we talked a lot about
why you might be disillusioned with mr
johnson let's let's see if we can um
do find any common ground here david
gawk um
is there anything that boris johnson
could do that would reconcile
you to his leadership
i don't think there is i i think he's
looking he's got
we know who boris johnson is he has been
a public figure for many many years
we know what his personality is like and
you know we know what his attitude is to
rules so
i don't think there's anything
people don't change in their late 50s
don't change their personality
completely he will still be the same
person he has he has he has positive
qualities as well as negative qualities
but for me i don't think he is uh
someone who is
up to being prime minister who is fit to
be prime minister of a country like the
united kingdom and i would say you know
if he didn't have the integrity on
monday he still doesn't have the
necessary integrity on tuesday
regardless of how many people supported
him in a no-confidence vote but isn't
the problem here that is it's not just
about morrison your objection to him is
not just about boris johnson the person
but uh his stand on the issue that
matters to you which is brexit yeah no
there's i i don't deny that clearly not
everybody who opposed him yesterday were
uh you know have their concerns about
brexit when you look at you know steve
baker and david davis and julian lewis
and andrew bridgeson and so on there but
very much john barron there were very
many brexiteers who voted against uh
boris johnson but yes i think he is
responsible for
a serious mistake for this for this
country and has taken us in the wrong
direction on that but look you know he
won the referendum he won the general
election in 2019
uh and you know so so beerus i i think
he's wrong about those things but the
issue here for the conservative party i
think is is the question of integrity
which is why people who have very
different views to mine on brexit think
he should go all right ann whitaker mum
you've taken on many challenges in your
life um 45 seconds persuade david gawk
that he's wrong
david um you may not like brexit but i
can't believe that you would like a
labor government
and therefore i think you should ask
yourself what is the best way forward
now whatever your personal reservations
may be now everybody will remember that
i famously fell out with michael howard
but once he'd been elected leader of the
conservative party i supported him
because i just knew uh that we had to
get on with the job
and that is now what i think is so
important we don't want to disappoint
people david about leveling up
about the conservative agenda we can't
do it if we're divided and fractious and
and arguing the public simply
won't take it and i would say this to
you do you really want to think the day
after the next general election if we've
got a labor government that you might
have contributed to that david gawk the
greater good
well i i worry about an argument that
says
uh look there are some
flaws here serious flaws i mean you know
anne whitaker would not in a million
years have behaved in the way that boris
johnson has
on a number of things but because
because i want to stop labor because you
know i'm i'm of the conservative tribe
or you know and i i believe in
conservative policies we can overlook
these things
i think is a is a is a dangerous
argument i think that that that that
means that we turn up we turn a blind
eye to failings that we would
strongly condemn if it was coming from
another party but because it's our own
party we let it go i don't think that's
good enough craig we're together and
with goodness had to go failed why don't
you try well i'm playing him i'm just
going to tell david to shake his head
because uh
uh
you know no matter how we feel
personally the conservative party is a
broad church it's always been a broad
church and i know i was a whip when when
you were in in cabinets and and i i know
had a very good one uh thank you
connolly you're you you okay stop
complaining
because the reality is no matter where
we sit in that broad broad church
the reality is boris johnson was elected
to this country
as a prime minister of this country with
a huge majority of 80.
that wasn't from
the small constituency of parliamentary
party that was from the british people
and boris johnson's character has been
known for time and eternity um
you know it's it's a bit like donald
trump isn't it you you uh you know
people were surprised at donald trump's
actions when all he was doing was uh
what he said he was going to do uh you
know why are we surprised when we see
these these flaws that we know have
always been there with boris johnson but
the british people have elected them
i i i was elected by the people of the
call the valley as you were elected when
you're uh
an mp uh by your constituents and and we
need to serve them in the best interest
okay craig i i want to pick you up a
point but david briefly
still not convinced still not convinced
and and yeah okay he he he he won a
general election i mean you know look
where the polling is now if we're going
to base this and this is i think
something the conservative party should
be very cautious about yeah the idea
that boris johnson has got the
popularity today that he had in 2019 and
remember he he won that election because
people wanted to get brexit done rightly
or in my view wrongly
and
they wanted to keep corbin out
rightly
in my view uh now
those arguments aren't going to be there
at the next general election strip those
away from boris johnson are we sure he's
still the the miracle vote harvester
that he was in 2019 i'm just not
convinced that that's true either but
that is that isn't my fundamental
argument my fundamental argument is it
doesn't meet the standards craig why
don't we um actually put this to the
test because what we're really talking
about here is the question about
johnson's electability and so on and so
forth
why doesn't he call the general election
let's clean this all up right now
you're asking me with why he doesn't why
shouldn't he uh
because there's lots more to do uh that
you know the program there's always lots
more to do
you're actually saying and one one of
the things that you said before
yesterday was that um the government
can't do its job really because it's got
to get past all of this let's clean it
all up have a general election the
people will speak and will no doubt say
that the people will speak in favor of
johnson david will say they won't why
don't you so when we get in on what
you're asking then is whenever we get an
unpopular period of time with the prime
minister we call the general election
that's not how i like ours this is an
unusual specific thing why not why is it
unusual we had the same we had a much
worse scenario when when we had the
theresa may government in fact we had a
paralysis of parliament and then you did
clean it up but but eventually we did
but but you know people like david at
the time
if i remember correctly
uh wouldn't allow a general election to
be called because of the rules at the
time so but no i no i don't agree with
that this couple you know we've
mentioned leveling up and all the good
conservative things that are happening
there is lots of good things happening
under this government unfortunately
nobody's talking about them because of
what's been going on the calder valley
has had half a billion pounds worth of
leveling up money over the last decade i
mean it's huge vast sums of money that
places like mine have never seen in the
history of the seat all right well very
briefly one of the things that we do on
this programme is that trevor gets to
advance um a solution which everybody
rejects so let me try try this on you
quick very quickly uh and we're to come
if boris johnson were to announce that
this is going to be his next last
election campaign um do you think that
would be a good offer to make to the
people who want him out
do you mean that he'll
fight next time or you mean that he
won't fight next time he'll fight the
next election rather as tony blair did
uh in uh you know back in the 2000s he
said this is going to be my last
election and uh i won't find the fight
again
no i mean i think that is absolutely
followed because we won the general
election that's a vote of confidence
from the british people so why shouldn't
he go on i i do not believe that he
should do that i certainly don't think
there should be a general election now
because bluntly he does
david what about you
yeah no i'm i'm not convinced by i don't
think it's particularly in in boris
johnson's interest so he's not going to
do it um but i i think that's uh it's
neither one thing nor the other you know
either he is fit to be prime minister in
which case you know he can carry on
until he's defeated or he chooses to go
or he's he's not fit to be prime
minister in which case he should go as
soon as possible uh if he were to step
down from the leadership would you um by
the way rejoin the conservative party uh
i'd wait and see i'd uh i'd want to see
what happens to the conservative party
i'm not going to rush to rejoin the
conservative party i'd want to hear from
the new leader and see what he or she
has to say oh that's strange because the
conservative party is a conservative
party whether it's boris johnson or not
and
one can see why you wouldn't want to be
in it under this leadership but why
would you not join and be part of the
new
thing whatever it is well i i worry that
the the conservative party is changing
more fundamentally that this is not just
about boris johnson that there's a
realignment of british politics going on
and that um the conservative party of
say david cameron uh essentially as a
liberal internationalist
uh type of party i think is is possibly
no longer there just just very briefly
craig isn't david gork's point here
right that the underlying issue here
it's not really boris johnson it's a
conservative party and that you as a
party cannot yet decide what kind of
party you are
no i don't think that's true at all i
mean every every aspect of life evolves
as time goes on i i would agree that
actually we need to get back to
conservative principles in governments
but of course what's happened over the
last two years
is preventing some of that stuff i'm
talking about low tax economy i'm
talking about getting rid of the nanny
state interfering in various aspects of
our lives whether it's the uh gambling
review or whether it's uh
uh
promotion of uh uh you know multi-pack
foods and all those types of things uh
we need to get back down to good
conservative core principles which i
think david and anne and i all agree
is what conservatism is actually about
well look thank you all very much uh i
think we can be absolutely certain about
one thing there is not yet common ground
between the different factions of the
conservative tribe as david galk called
it but what
the majority here seem to think is that
it is possible
it is possible you can see a path to
victory under boris johnson it's not yet
exactly clear but it probably exists but
i think david gork's point is underneath
this and one i agree with that the
conservative party has to get a clearer
uh
personality and clearer offer about what
it is in the modern world we'll see
whether the
leader tomorrow or next week or next
month whoever that might be can do that
thank you all very much indeed
that's it for this week my thanks to our
guests and thank you for watching
and listening
stay with us we'll have all of today's
news coming up after the break
[Music]